[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight like most people you
probably haven't been watching a lot of
CNN lately but you may have heard they
staged a televised town hall meeting on
gun control last night it seemed like
one of those cultural moments worth
being aware of and so for educational
purposes we want to show you a clip a
short clip of what happened here it is
wait sorry I'm so sorry that was
actually the two minutes hate scene from
1984 the film version of George Orwell's
novel would that the footage confused it
was easy to do here's the CNN version of
that I think what you're asking about is
the assault weapons ban yes sir so let
me be honest with you about that one if
I believed that that law would have
prevented this from happening I would
support it but I want to explain to you
why it would not can you tell me right
now that you will not accept a single
donation from the NRA
I wish the NRA lady I could have talked
to because I would ask her how she can
look in the mirror considering the fact
that she has children let me answer the
question let me answer the question you
can shout me down when I'm finished but
let me answer in this question he should
have been barred from getting a firearm
and he should not have been able to he
should not have been able to purchase
the fire on so if I could change time
and change circumstances I would have
done everything in my power to prevent
that you just told this group of people
that you are standing up for them you're
not standing up for them I want to thank
deena lash of the NRA and also sheriff
Scott Israel for being here to listen to
your questions
[Applause]
emotions were inflamed and obviously we
understand why but yelling and nastiness
don't help anyone it's precisely in
times of tragedy and distress that we
need the comest and most thoughtful
voices CNN last night brought us the
opposite they did it to make money but
they also did it for ideological reasons
that wasn't a town-hall meeting and it
certainly wasn't a news event it was an
act of ritual public humiliation for
anybody who disagrees with CNN's
transparently clear position against gun
rights
Dana lash was there last night she was
the one you just saw being called a
murderer on stage she spoke about her
experience earlier today many in legacy
media love mass shootings you guys love
it
now I'm not saying that you love the
tragedy but I am saying that you loved
the ratings
crying white mothers are ratings gold to
you and many in the legacy media in the
back and notice I said crying white
mothers because there are thousands of
grieving black mothers in Chicago every
weekend and you don't see
well she's certainly right about the
deep corruption of the news media how
corrupt well coltan hobb Junior ROTC
cadet who helped lead students to safety
during the shootings in Florida last
week went to the scene an event less
centered wanted to he says CNN producers
rewrote the question he wanted to ask
CNN denies scripting anything other
words they're claiming that Colton hub
is a liar